sport und gesunde ernährung sind
wichtige 3 für die liebes qualität aber
bis zu welchem grad so strebt immer
danach so auszusehen und die leute
wachsen einfach gleich in die essstörung
rein
ich bin ein genaues muster reingefallen
und zwar nennt sich das bulimia nervosa
ich hab ja viele von denen hier opfer
melden
die irgendwann gesagt haben ich kann es
nicht mehr mit meinem gewissen
vereinbaren
[Musik]
absichtlich fitness influenza ist es
wird schwierig wenn man es auf
natürlichem wege probiert
einer wohlen steroide dienen dazu
muskelmasse aufzubauen
als mir wurde auch schon häufig ganz
angeboten so was irgendwo hinzustellen
das schafft man nicht mit normalen
mitteln also dass da nicht an alles das
heißt irgendwann erreicht man giftige
dosis und fällt damit nur diese guten
körper aber die sind nicht die
geschichten dahinter
[Musik]